welcome everyone i'm susie valdez of
labyrinths and i will be your moderator
for this event thank you for joining us
for our presentation titled standard
test
method development process at astm
it's my pleasure to introduce you to our
speaker george gonzalez the director of
global
segment marketing at agilent
technologies american society
for testing and materials and the
chairman of the
subcommittee d02d for complete biography
on our speaker please visit the
tab at the top of your screen and if you
have any questions that arise during
this presentation
please we encourage you to submit them
in the q a box
our speaker will address those questions
following his presentation please join
me now
and welcome george gonzalez i will now
turn the presentation
over to him welcome george
hello everyone my name is george
gonzalez
i work for agilent technologies and i am
here to present
the standard test method development
process at astm
i'd like to begin with the agenda and
the first thing i'd like to
quote from the astm.org site
and the following which is the astm
process
transcends what entities could do
individually
because it bridges gaps of technology
combines resources
and overcomes lines of competition
the result is a product of the highest
credibility
integrity and marketplace acceptance
that is the core of what is
done at astm to develop standards
in this presentation i'm going to begin
by discussing the overall structure
of the committee and specify
a few details and of course the
standard development process is by
consensus
in the development of all standard test
methods
i will also cover standard development
hierarchy
and how it processes through the astm
promulgation process there's a hierarchy
and i will review that and provide more
details
the ballooning process is an iterative
process
and requires a ballot ad subcommittee
and a ballot at main committee to be
approved as a standard test method
the balloting process will be reviewed
in detail
in this presentation
and then the big question is why does it
take so long
to develop an astm standard if you
follow it the development of astm
standards
you'll see that it requires in the order
of one to three years
the promulgation time will be discussed
as well and then
to augment the description and
give an example of a collaboration
that was performed in the development of
two astm
standards i will provide that example
as well and then i will also provide
a few standards that i am working on
that currently are
in the development process
the first item on our agenda is the
fact that astm is a voluntary consensus
development
program
it is composed of many committees
the one that i am most familiar with and
i attend regularly
is astm d2 which is petroleum
products liquid fuels and lubricants
committee
it is part of the numerous technical
committees
that were formed to address specific
industry needs
such as those noted in the title
the main committee is then subdivided
into subcommittees the subcommittees
are there to address subsets of
specialized
subject matter the main committee has an
executive subcommittee
which oversees the subcommittees and
that is due d2
dot 90. then there's uh
lettered subcommittees for product
specifications so the product
subcommittees are designated
by a letter for example d2
d which is the subcommittee on
hydrocarbons
for chemicals and specialty use
now in this case i am the chairman
of this subcommittee
then there are property subcommittees
which are designated with a
subcommittee number for example d2
3 is for elemental analysis
and then there are coordinating
subcommittees for example subcommittee
91
92 93 etc
and those are for example statistical
quality
and numerous others coordinating
committees dedicated to supporting
the process of astm standards
now the subcommittees form
task groups based on the need to support
an active astm standard one that has
already been published
and is being revised or a task group
made
form to work on a new
standard test method so the task groups
are formed by
experts from industry to form
subcommittees that are organized into
groups to write standards
and to revise standards that are
currently active
those uh task groups form
the core source of
work at astm they perform
all of the actual
coordination of sample logistics
they perform the pilot studies they
coordinate the
interlaboratory studies they
write the astm standards and
with regards to writing astm standards
there are specifications and
requirements
that each standard must meet so these
are all defined in the
astm regulations to
for procedural process and promulgation
of the standards
and then the document itself must comply
with the standardized format and that is
based on astm form and style manual
which contains the directive and
instructions
and specifications that are required
for each standard so each standard meets
the minimum criteria for formatting
and the style
for and before
publication
the next item on our agenda is the
description
and and of the process in the standard
development hierarchy
as i mentioned before the
bulk of the work is performed by
the task groups uh the task groups
play the most if not the majority
of the work in the development of a
standard
uh a standard
begins with a technical presentation
presented at either of two in-person
stated meetings uh held either in june
and december this year
unfortunately the meeting this in-person
meetings
were cancelled due to the pandemic and
the effects
so most of those meetings and all of the
coordinating meetings were held
by teleconference
the majority of the work which includes
the technical presentation
uh then it moves to
a request for a work item which is
assigned by the
subcommittee a task group is then formed
and assigned to that work item
the task group is composed of
technical experts from the industry who
are
working to develop a standard for common
use
and then the draft document
is circulated within the task group
expert panel who then
agrees on a final draft
which is used to perform a pilot study
based on
astm d 6300 criteria
the results of the pilot study are then
used to design
the inter-laboratory study which
also has requirements
and are also stated in astm d
6300 the interlaboratory study
is for the purpose of collecting
test data which is then processed
for statistical analysis and the results
are published as the precision and bias
statement of the standard test method
once the task group completes their work
and their uh as agreement on occasion
there's some
unofficial voting within the task group
to assure that consensus at the task
group level
is met however it's unofficial and in
most cases
any dissensions or disagreements on
technical matter are addressed
at the task group once there is
agreement
however at the task group level the
proposed standard test method is
submitted to the subcommittee
for balloting balloting is performed
electro
by electronic basis
and it normally takes approximately 30
days
the ballot must have a 60 return rate
with two thirds approval in order to
move forward
now i'll not mention
the items that may hold up or
cause the ballot to fail and those are
negative votes i'll explain that
in the detailed review of the standard
promulgation process
if the
ballot passes that subcommittee
then the item the proposed test method
is then balloted at main committee
which has the same criteria and it
also has the same 30-day balloting
process
if it's approved that main then it moves
to
committee on standards for final review
and it also has a 30-day ballot review
with due process and it also has an
appeals process
at that point
so that is the general hierarchy of
how a standard moves through the astm
process
the astm balloting process begins with
a defined industry need for a standard
on occasion there are
test methods that become common practice
in the industry and those are based on
a need to measure a given parameter of a
product that is commercially traded
the original work is performed
at a laboratory and then the
industry method is then
shared within the industry and it
suddenly becomes uh prevalent but
is not a standard test method
so in those cases when there are at
least six laboratories
that are using a an industry method
that has not been published it is
possible
that that is a an identified need
and justifiable as a proposed
test method so when that becomes
necessary this industry need for a
standard
can then be presented
at a technical presentation at a stated
meeting
at astm d2 as i mentioned those meetings
are held in
june and december and they're held
and conducted in
several cities within
north america
the technical presentation then provides
access to
a work item typically the person
presenting
the technical presentation is considered
the technical contact for
the work item and that person will then
lead the effort
and the task group in the development
of a standard test method
the task group then moves on
to collect data first as i mentioned
there's a pilot study based on astm d
6300 then there's an intra laboratory
study or
ils that is used to collect data
for the precision and bias study
and then
the task group will draft
the proposed standard in the final form
to be submitted the proposed standard
must meet
with astm form and style manual criteria
before it's submitted for
balloting the draft is then
approved at subcommittee
for balloting the ballot then
requires and is open for 30 days
it's an electronic balloting process
the balloting process is open to voting
members
of each committee and subcommittee
so during the 30-day review
and balloting process each member
can either vote affirmative
or negative if there is a negative vote
it requires a comment
as a technical concern regarding
the proposed standard
if there are no negatives
the ballot with the proposed ballot item
with the proposed
standard moves on the main committee
ballot however
if there are any negatives the rules of
the balloting process
state that all negatives must be
resolved
before it can move on to the main
committee ballot
so if there is a negative
the technical contact
for the work item works to resolve any
negatives
and comments and then
there's a decision tree
if the negative comment is persuasive
but it is a change that is not editorial
then the standard is revised and sent
back to the
subcommittee for rebalancing
if through the resolution process
that proposed or required change
concerning the negative is an editorial
or if the negative is withdrawn after
discussion
or in the worst case
if the negative voter refuses to work
with the technical contact in resolving
that
the negative vote
it is possible to find
the negative vote non-persuasive
that process requires presentation of
uh adjudication at a stated meeting
during the june meeting or the december
meeting
so if the vote is editorial
and can move on or if the negative vote
is withdrawn or if it's found
non-persuasive then it can move on
to main committee for balloting
the main committee balloting process
requires
30 days and again it goes through the
same process
during the balloting process if you have
negative votes and comments they have to
be addressed
and the same decision tree is used
to resolve negatives as in the one that
was described for the subcommittee
if there are no negative votes it
me it moved the standard test method
moves on to the committee on standards
for review and then
published after that
so the big question as i mentioned most
people have
regarding astm standards and and some
other
standard development organizations it
takes time to develop a standard
and the big question is why does it take
so long
and the answer is it takes as long as it
takes
and as i mentioned also
the each standard test method is unique
it also as you may consider
requires resources it requires requires
materials it requires instrument time
it requires a shipment of samples to
each location and
then more importantly it requires a
dedicated
effort of a collaborator to run
the samples for both the pilot study
and the inter laboratory
study so all of that
work as you might imagine requires a
significant amount of time
and in the process there are
an unknown amount of variables that
require time
to complete so in this process
as you notice the timeline the pre-work
performed by the task group
in the process of method development and
establishing the precision
through a precision study and all of the
work i just mentioned
requires x amount of time
and i i can't
begin to express that the more complex
methods require
a significantly more amount of time
and then the work item begins at time
zero that's
as the work item is presented and then
of course then you have the balloting
process that subcommittee ballot
at about six months and then the main
committee ballot if it passes directly
to maine that's 12 months
and then review and publication
so the
fastest possible completion is one year
you have the technical presentation the
work item
and if the standard has already been
worked
to a point where the precision study and
all of the work
has been completed to to that point then
it can be completed in one year
but more typical it requires between 18
to 36 months
to establish and publish an astm
standard
now there's also additional
time required because at
the five year mark after publication or
last revision
there is a review of the standard
that means that the standard must be
reviewed by
the subcommittee and re-balloted for
a re-approval so all standards at astm
are reviewed at least every
at minimum every five years in order to
be
continued in publication
so you see these are all variables that
answer the question why does it take
so long to publish a standard
as you can see there's a significant
amount of work for each standard
required
what i'd like to do now is provide a
collaboration example
of one that i am personally acquainted
with
we at agilent started a collaboration
to establish two astm standards as you
may see there is
astm standard for crude oil the
elemental analysis
of crude oil and residual fuel oil
by mpaes
that standard was published this past
july a couple of months ago
and
at the same time a standard
test method was in promulgation
concurrently at the same time
as the one that has already been
published so that gives you an
idea of the complexity of even
using the same platform the mpaes
to run two different three different
types of
fuels the collaborating team is shown
there
it was a global collaboration with 12
laboratories performing the pilot study
and the inter laboratory precision study
that is our collaborating team shown at
the
bottom left now what i'd like to do is
briefly go over the timeline
for the development of this standard
the program timeline to establish the
8322
we began the and presented the technical
presentation
at the astm meeting in june of 2017.
in that meeting we requested two work
items
one for what is now d8322
and one for the second proposed standard
work item 56916
that proposed standard is still in the
balancing process
the pilot study for
this test method was completed in july
of 2018.
the work to establish and get to
a pilot study as you can see is just a
little over one year
and that's coordinating shipment of
pilot study
well preparing the samples for the pilot
study
and everything involved with
distribution and testing
completion and processing the
statistical data
it required approximately one year
the inter laboratory study which
is a much more rigorous
study required
that each laboratory test three fuels
two for crude oil and residual oil and
the biodiesel samples that
interlaboratory study was completed in
march of
2019
both of these proposed standards
were submitted for subcommittee ballot
in may
of 2019 they were concurrently performed
all three of these intra-laboratory
studies there was an interlaboratory
study conducted for crude oil
one for residual fuel oil and one for
biodiesel
they were completed and then in
started and added to the proposed test
methods as the precision for each
proposed test method
that ballot submitted in may of 2019
received a negative vote
which required adjudication and
resolution
the negative vote could not be resolved
without significant changes
to to the standard and in this case
the majority of the concerns or negative
comments
were related to the description
of the working range
and the valid test result range defined
as new items
in astm d6300
the astm d 6300 defines the precision
and bias
criteria as well as the working range
and the valid test result range that
caused
confusion and significant changes
were required to the
proposed test method so we had to reball
it
in july of 2019
that ballot also generated
additional negatives
and i adjudicated that negative
in at the stated meeting in december of
2019
that negative was found non-persuasive
therefore the proposed standards
moved on as as far as d8322 is concerned
it moved on to main committee ballot now
at this time the
second standard had to be re-balloted at
subcommittee for a third time
so that's not shown here but it started
falling behind
then the main committee ballot
produced no negative votes there was one
item
that was resolved and the standard
d8322 was published in july
of this year so that's an example
of a collaboration
of two standards performed by the same
collaborating team using the same
instrument platform however
one of the work items moved on to be
published as d8322
and the second work item is still
invalid
and as of this moment today i'm working
on
some negative votes at the main
committee so that gives you an idea of
the challenge
that we're up against when we're
establishing an astm standard
and it can also provide some insight
to the robustness of the process at astm
so the current standards in development
at astm
those that i am working on
are shown here now the first one is
there
basically because it just went from
work item status to published astm
standard
and that is the standard test method
for determination of elements in
residual fuels and crude oils by
microwave plasma atomic emission
spectroscopy
the mpaes that was published in july
and we've moved on
the next item
is the second standard which is still in
work item status
the work item is 56916
again the only difference there is that
the test method is for determination
of elements in biodiesel blends up to
b100
if we work through to resolve the
negatives
currently on ballot i hope to complete
that by the end of this year in december
the other item that i am working on
is at committee d2
dot 4 subcommittee m
for mass spec the
test method for work item
50453 is the standard test method for
determination of chemical species
in marine fuel oil by multi-dimensional
gas chromatography mass spectrometry
we are currently in the process of
conducting an inter-laboratory study
for the precision and bias statement of
that standard
d7845 in addition we have a second work
item with a request that we received
for expansion of the scope
so that's work item 56072
the expansion of the scope for this test
method
includes components which cannot be
performed
by the current sample preparation
procedure
so that requires twofold
requires a new sample preparation
procedure
as well as an interlaboratory study
when we complete that the goal
is to develop the new procedure
for the additional components and
incorporate
the new procedure as procedure b
with the current procedure in d7845
as procedure a i am currently
collaborating with intertek
on that work
then we also have uh some joint work
with bureau veritas as
we revise astm
d8110 at present
d8110 was published with conditional
provisional precision data
and it's for the elemental analysis of
metal distillates by icp mass spec
the goal is to expand the scope of the
element table capabilities
and to include crude oil analysis by icp
mass spec
so those are the standard test methods
that i am working
on and moving at
astm
so one note and to make sure
the information that i provided is based
on my experience
and the resources that i have at
astm.org
i would recommend and suggest
that you join astm
possibly attend the biennial meetings if
you're interested in participating
and also and more important as you
might have noticed there's a significant
amount of work
performed by the task groups and as
as a technical contact for multiple
standards
it is uh challenging to find
participating labs
and i and i truly understand why because
i've managed laboratories
in the past at contract labs and
i know the volume of work that is
performed
in most laboratories
it makes it difficult to add additional
load of sample testing
to participate in an ils but
it's vitally important to continue to
expand the volunteer list
so that we can have additional support
and resources that help to develop
standards
so you can go to the website astm.org
and get all of the details required
beyond
what i obviously have provided here
and in closing the disclaimer is that
this is not inclusive of what
is required to establish a standard it
is merely
an overview and if you need
additional details you may contact
the staff at astm.org
thank you for your time today i believe
we're moving on to the questions and
comments
section of the presentation have a good
day
thank you george for that outstanding
presentation
we will now move to the live q a portion
of the presentation
as a reminder please submit your
questions via the q
a box we welcome all questions now
george our first question from our
audience member
is are all the subcommittees organized
the same way yes
uh for the most part the the difference
is going to be
with the task groups uh some are are
more specialized
in in terms of being able to address
the requirements for each specific
standard as i mentioned
all of these standards have different
procedures different apparatus
and different capabilities so
the task group can expand and
and you know may have on the order of
100 or or so
collaborators participating in the task
group
so effectively they're all the same it's
just the
size and the number of participants in
each task group
and what about membership do we have to
be a member of
astm to participate
so that if
the person is is interested
in reviewing and
the standards as they're valid in the
electronic process
you do need to be a member for that
process and
when you join uh you select the
committee which would be
this case d2 and also you need to select
the subcommittees that you're interested
in and they're all listed
on the website so once you do that
as ballots are um
rolled out electronically you will
receive an update
and as you can access the ballot on on
the astm website
so that part you do have to be a member
however
there are quite a few labs you know as i
mentioned
for the intro interlaboratory studies
not all of the folks that are
participating running the samples
and even for the expert panel
they're not all members of astm they're
folks that volunteer their time
to develop a standard that can be used
in their lab and
and shared for the industry
so for participating within the task
group
and all of that work uh donating
chemicals and reagents and
you know other things all of that is
effectively the majority as i mentioned
the majority of the
work to develop a standard you can also
participate in drafting the method and
adding your comments and your experience
and your expertise you can join the task
group
but you do not have to be an astm
member for that
george gonzalez thank you again for your
presentation today
and for your important research and i
want to thank our audience
audience for our outstanding questions
throughout the conference
any questions that were submitted and
not answered today by our speaker
will be addressed via email and this
presentation will be available for
on-demand viewing
through september 2021 please share it
with a colleague who may
be interested in today's topic and thank
you again for your participation
we hope you enjoyed the agilent science
and technology virtual symposium
until next time stay safe stay healthy
bye everyone bye